bonjour gay humains à leur grosse
actualité concernant le bassin sanitaire
et la vaccination aujourd'hui à
commencer par cette loi qui est débattu
au sénat aujourd'hui l'extension de
l'obligation vaccinale à toute la
population est ce que cette loi a une
chance d'être adoptés bonjour magali
bonjour à tous les deux à leur nombre a
en théorie cette loi de retraite cette
loi proposition de loi socialiste
devrait être rejeté par les sénateurs
comme du reste a été rejetée il ya une
semaine en commission des affaires
sociales les forces en présence ne sont
tout simplement pas suffisante pour que
cette obligation vaccinale soit étendu à
toute la population alors certes le
groupe socialiste est le second groupe
majoritaire au sénat mais il a en face
de lui les républicains très largement
majoritaire est très largement opposée à
cette mesure comme du reste et bien
d'autres élus de tous bords écouter
aller vers implique de se rendre auprès
des personnes âgées à domicile dans les
déserts médicaux
car elles ne bénéficient pas de la
vaccination dans ces conditions
introduire l'obligation vaccinale
d'autant plus avec des sanctions me
semble disproportionné son exécution
pose problème adopter une politique
publique sans pouvoir la faire exécuter
c'est se mettre en situation
d'impuissance public s'est discrédité
l'action publique à moins d'un
retournement de situation inattendu et
très très improbable cette extension de
l'obligation vaccinale à toute la
population ne devrait pas voir le jour
ne devrait pas être adopté par les
sénateurs aujourd'hui aurait pas
d'obligation humain mais cette très
forte incitation avec le pass à lithaire
qu'il devrait être prolongé et oui tout
à fait olivier alors précision il ne
s'agit pas très exactement de prolonger
le pass salutaire pour le gouvernement
mais de conserver la possibilité d'y
avoir recours aux besoins et jusqu'à
l'été 2022 alors une nuance qui les noie
n'y pas les critiques d'autant que le 31
juillet 2022 donc et la date de fin de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire prévu dans ce
projet de loi est bien c'est au delà de
l'élection présidentielle c'est au delà
de
du mandat des manuels mâcon ce qui là
aussi a suscité de vives réactions y
compris du côté des parlementaires qui
veulent garder un certain contrôle sur
cette prolongation écouter
le contrôle du parlement ça veut dire
qu'en février nous devront débattre à
nouveau de la poursuite du processus de
sortie d'urgence le pass sanitaire est
une atteinte aux libertés individuelles
et collectives et ça ne peut se faire
que sous le contrôle du parlement dans
une démocratie parlementaire
alors le second personnage de l'état qui
ne souhaite pas donner de blanc seing au
gouvernement sauf que l'on connaît la
composition du parlement et de ses
chambres des chambres parfois réduites à
de simples chambres d'enregistrement
c'est ce qu'ont tout con parfois
regretter certains élus d'opposition au
cours de cette crise une opposition se
passe à dire qui s'exprime aussi dans la
rue depuis plusieurs mois on le voit
bien et oui et maya devient tout à fait
des manifestations qui se succèdent
depuis cet été et un ras-le-bol qui se
fait de plus en plus sentir un
ras-le-bol du pass sanitaire même si la
contestation baisse en intensité au fur
et à mesure des des semaines au fur et à
mesure dès samedi et aujourd'hui ce sont
les lieux culturels qui ont décidé de se
faire entendre et plus précisément les
personnels des bibliothèques journée de
grève nationale certains jugent
incompatible les mesures sanitaires avec
leur mission de service public alors
certaines bibliothèques certains
établissements établissements fermeront
leurs portes d'autres ne contrôleront
pas les passes sanitaires à l'entrée des
bibliothèques et d'autres actions sont
attendus un peu partout en france merci
guy main on suivra ça bien évidemment
sur rt france au cours de la journée
ghislain rosier en direct de la
rédaction darty france ce matin